we all remember playing with
fingerboards as a kid but this man
turned fingerboarding into his career
and lifelong passion my name is mike
schneider i'm a professional finger
boarder and i'm the owner of flat face
fingerboards since he was about 10 years
old he's been building his own
fingerboards and customizing his own
scaled-down skateparks and he's been
shredding ever since
[Music]
[Applause]
learning a new trick do you think it's
more painful on a skateboard or on a
fingerboard
learning a trick on a real skateboard is
definitely more painful because you can
actually get hurt doing it
so i started finger boarding in
4th grade
i had just started skateboarding shortly
before that and i was totally hooked it
was awesome
and so kids in my fourth grade class had
fingerboards tech decks and they were
playing with them during class and
during recess and i just thought it was
the coolest thing ever so that's where
it all started
a lot of my first fingerboarding was
done on books and we would stack them to
make stair sets and stuff like that so
you can be really creative and you can
fingerboard just about anywhere
you might be able to fingerboard
anywhere but mike has spent most of his
life creating the ultimate fingerboard
park
he spends well over 40 hours a week
surrounded by miniature skateboards and
his collection of tiny skate parks
we are in the flat face fingerboards
building in dracut massachusetts it's
basically a huge building full of
fingerboard parks there's at least 25 of
them in here so you can come in and just
fingerboard all day long and it's just
an awesome place for people to get
together and have fun
[Music]
the first trick i remember learning was
a varial flip i was trying a kickflip
and it kept doing varial flips so i got
really good at varial flips
one big moment that i can remember
learning how to fingerboard that was
pretty profound was like the first time
that i did a kickflip nose slide because
it took me an hour like straight one
hour at my desk trying it over and over
again
not doing it and then all of a sudden i
did it and i noticed my camera was off
the battery had died so i didn't even
get it on film but it was more of like
all right i actually just did this thing
that i thought was impossible then i
realized i could pretty much learn any
trick if i just apply myself to it
there's a lot of really complex tricks
that i do and once i do them they feel
easy afterwards but it takes a long time
to get to that point so it's kind of
always growing and evolving over time
19 years of intense practice has given
mike a catalog of tricks that rivals any
skater to grace a thrasher cover
so the most basic trick is an ollie and
that's just a simple jump where the
board appears to be stuck to your
fingers but it's not
the way that it works is that your
middle finger is going to pop the board
against the ground where the board kind
of gets momentum from hitting the ground
and then you're basically lifting your
hand with it guiding it and then when
you've reached the peak and level out
then you just go back down with it
so once you've mastered the ollie people
usually move on to kick flip which is
one of these
basically you pop it like an ollie then
you flick it with this finger which
makes the board flip
and then when it's done flipping you
land on it and then you land on the
ground
next you could learn something like a
varial flip
which is a kickflip where the board also
turns 180 degrees
then after that you can do a tray flip
which is a 360 degree rotation plus a
kick flip
instead of popping straight down with
your back finger you're basically
scooping it a little as you pop like
that and that's what's setting the
spinning rotation and then you're
flicking it similar to a normal kick
flip with your front finger then you can
start turning your whole hand with it
you can do like a front side flip back
side flip spinning the other direction
big flip which is like a tray flip with
the 180.
so there's tons of levels and then you
can combine more and more things
together i could do a kickflip to late
impossible so an impossible where you
wrap it around your finger but i can do
like a kickflip first
i got it first try
yeah it's hard to believe it's so hard
when you're making it
that's the thing once you learn it it's
not really that hard but until you get
to the point where you can do it it's
super hard if i invent the trick i'd
probably name it rhombus after my cat
just like real life skating mike is
constantly pushing himself to master new
tricks
once you have all kinds of tricks you've
learned you can incorporate them onto
different elements of different skate
parks doing tricks in different
combinations so the possibilities are
endless
when i want to learn a new trick i
pretty much just go for it
fingerboarding and skateboarding are
both kind of trial and error and just
learning what doesn't work in order to
learn what does work so you have a
vision of how you think a trick should
be done and each time that you try it
again there's a slight adjustment so you
might be moving one of your fingers into
a different spot or faster or slower a
different angle and all that kind of
stuff comes together and then you'll
notice that you're either getting closer
and closer to landing it or you're
getting farther from it and then you can
keep adjusting a lot of times when i
have a trick in mind i kind of have a
spot in mind for it some of them are
pretty specific and then other times if
it's something more basic you can really
do it anywhere which is cool
it's still crazy to me even though i've
been doing it for so long that i built
what i built and then i made the boards
and everything like when i'm using a
board that i made on one hand i'm used
to it but on the other hand it's like
wow i really made a board that i think
at least for me it works better than any
other fingerboard so it's really
satisfying in that way
[Music]
in his quest for the ideal fingerboard
mike decided to just do it himself so in
his humble basement in massachusetts
mike estimates he's built thousands of
decks over the years and shipped them
out to customers all over the globe
all right so we're going to mold a board
here we're going to start out by cutting
the wood it's this really thin maple
which is going to be layered and then
molded into shape
so we'll cut two plies with the wood
grain horizontal and then there's going
to be three with vertical grain
so that keeps it basically so that the
shape will hold over time it just keeps
the whole thing really strong and sturdy
now that we've got our wood cut we're
going to glue it together and put it in
the mold which will give it its shape
the plastic wrap is just to keep
everything clean so it doesn't make a
huge mess everywhere on the mold
this is the mold it's got the shape of
the board and
the wood just goes right in it and then
you squeeze it in here
the molding process takes several hours
in order for the board to fully harden
and be ready for sanding so while the
board sits in there i picked out another
board that i've already molded so i can
continue showing the process
[Music]
so basically it starts out as a
rectangle and you need to sand it to the
right width and then you have to sand
the nose and tail to be round so it's
going to end up looking like a
skateboard shape and it just helps with
performance and everything
[Music]
all right so now the board is finished
being sanded into shape as you can tell
it's got that skateboard shape to it and
it's pretty much ready for the next step
mike's process for lacquering and
finishing his boards is proprietary but
after several hours that recently sanded
piece of wood looks and feels just like
a real skateboard first we're gonna put
the trucks on these are made in germany
and they're super realistic just like a
real skate truck and they have bushings
they can turn and they got lock nuts and
all that so they're gonna screw on to
the board pretty much how you do it on a
skateboard
luckily most people like to put their
own boards together so we pretty much
just sell the parts and people do it
themselves
i think my favorite part of putting
together a board is kind of the whole
thing like each step is pretty
satisfying the way that the trucks go on
when the holes are perfect is nice and
then just getting the wheels on and
putting the tape it's just a really good
feeling like
time you set up a new board it's really
exciting no matter what
and there it is
the decks have evolved a lot the first
ones that i made they were pretty good
but if you compare them to now they're
all super shiny and perfect and uniform
every time and back then it was kind of
hit or miss because i was still learning
what i was doing and really making them
as i go kind of in an always tweaking
the dimensions and the shapes basically
every single upgrade was oh i think if i
change this part it'll make it a little
better if i just move the nose and tail
shorter or farther away from each other
like all these little movements and
adapting it as i went along made it into
what it is today and now it's like
pretty much perfect
i think my favorite thing about the
fingerboard community is just how much
joy it brings to everybody because it
doesn't matter who you are or where
you're from it's just like everybody
gets along really well and a lot of us
have made like lifelong friends through
the whole process you can just do it
anywhere you see the world in a
different way because you'll see
something that looks like a ramp that
nobody who doesn't fingerboard would
ever notice but because you fingerboard
you're just like oh i gotta do at least
one trick on that and so it just kind of
makes the world like more exciting